this video is sponsored by
workingbiotech.com
healthcare is one of the four major
global problems we face
how can we make effective medicines that
are cheap and widely accessible
well this requires biology and
technology
biotechnology
technology that uses biology or biology
combined with technology
but anyway translating all this biology
science stuff to effective therapeutics
requires identification of effective
treatments
safety testing testing of
bioavailability pharmacokinetics
clinical trial primary endpoints then
manufacturing and production of the
therapeutic
and this all requires funding and the
right team behind it to make it happen
one field of biotech has been growing
rapidly over the last few years
rejuvenation biotech
and it doesn't look like it's slowing
down
so why what do you need to know about it
and what are the promises and challenges
they face
well we'll address these questions in
this video
so to start with what even is
rejuvenation biotech
well from the early work of nuclear
cloning from john garden's frog
experiments to the cloning of dolly the
sheep it was known that there was
potential for turning back the
biological clock
in the case of dolly she was the first
mammal cloned from an adult cell
the dna containing nucleus of an adult
cell was taken out and placed in an
unfertilized egg
this was then used to make dolly
during dolly's life she gave birth to
six lambs and this proved for the first
time that a cell taken from a specific
part of the body could recreate a whole
individual
and somehow the nucleus of the adult
cell with the genetic information was
getting reset or you could say
rejuvenated
such that it could go on to generate
dolly
but human cloning isn't what these
rejuvenation companies are working on
well at least as far as i can tell you
from the publicly available data so what
are they doing
well a more recent landmark in
rejuvenation came from shenya yamanaka
of the now termed yamanaka factors
four factors oct4 sucks ii klf4 and mc
that when expressed in differentiated
cells converted them back to stem
cell-like cells
so-called induced pluripotent stem cells
and these cells have the potential to
define and replicate but also to turn
back into different cell types
you could do this inside an individual
so called infivo
or take the cells out eg with blood
cells reprogram them and differentiate
them and then put them back so called
xva approaches
anyway most of the excitement is with
the in vivo approaches since it is
thought to have a larger impact and
recently i've reported on some latest
publications using these different
reprogramming technologies in mice
the strategy more frequently employed
now is partial reprogramming
rejuvenation without losing a cell's
identity but still with the potential to
get rejuvenated
the rationale is out with this approach
it's thought to be effective but also
safer as it reduces the likelihood of
tumors or teratomas from forming
but what commercial potential do they
have for therapeutics and what companies
are out there
well this table shows a pretty
up-to-date list of companies that are in
the so-called rejuvenation tech space
you have ajax therapeutics developing
tissue regeneration
outdoor slabs the humongous startup with
3 billion in funding for basic research
to then develop rejuvenation programming
therapeutics
calico the google spinout started in
2013 which seems to also now be shifting
focus to rejuvenation gemito focusing on
ovarian aging
i do know therapy6 using just osk for
reprogramming
new limit co-founded by brian armstrong
who i spoke to at the end of last year
retro biosciences a new company with the
mission to add 10 years to healthy human
lifespan who've more recently announced
that they've got 180 million in funding
for three programmes in cellular
reprogramming autophagy and plasma
inspired therapeutics
shift bioscience who actually gave me a
tour around their building
turned by technology's mrna
reprogramming and youth bio all working
more in partial reprogramming
but what is the potential well biotech
in general has been having some great
interest and success lately take a look
here at this chart that shows the quick
recovery of biotech in the spring of
2020
although it's fair to say that this was
largely driven due to the excitement
around finding treatment or preventative
solutions to covered 19.
and although the chart only goes up to
2021 and i know in general markets have
been a bit all over the place since then
it nonetheless still feels like a new
wake-up call for interest in the
potential of biotech
in fact it was during the pandemic that
altos labs was ideated by yuri mona and
rick klausner on a morning walk in
california
apparently
so why is biotech and rejuvenation
biotech staying so hot
well i think there are two main drivers
innovation and demand
the innovation stems from the continual
development of research tools and
cheaper costs of high throughput
sequencing and testing this includes
things like crispr single cell omics
tools whether it be looking at the
transcriptome methylome chromatin
structure or dna sequencing
as well as the incorporation of machine
learning to interpret this vast amount
of data being generated
and then demand
first is the changing demographics
a combination of both longer lives and
declining birth rates has resulted in
there being more people over 65 than
under five years and this trend is
predicted to keep increasing
the problem is that healthcare hasn't
kept up and the growing population
threatens the healthcare sector
treating the diseases of aging like
cancer neurodegeneration and
cardiovascular disease is expensive and
so the idea is that a more cost
effective strategy would be to just
target aging
and this could be something given and
tailored to everyone
and the idea of these rejuvenation
approaches is that they don't just slow
down the progression of these diseases
but would hopefully prevent or even
reverse some of the disease
manifestations
so there's demands and this demand was
boosted again by covered 19 which raised
awareness of how much pressure can be
placed on the healthcare sector when
we're ill-prepared
now ultimately many of these companies
are new and are riding this wave of
innovation and understanding and demand
for treatments
but what challenges do these companies
and well biotech companies in general
actually face
well i've just listed here a couple of
ideas that will probably come to your
mind as well such as the approach
they're taking their model tissue or
organism to work with whether it's in
vivo xvivo
whether whether they're doing it in mice
or human cells
how are they going to deal with the fact
that aging isn't considered a disease
what would be their clinical trials
based on
what is their therapeutic modality is it
efficient is it safe do they have fda
regulation
and then there's the more generic
challenges of actually trying to hire
the right
team as there seems to be to some extent
more capital available than talent and
this is better reflected in this crate i
found from a mckinsey article
if the industry is to maintain its
reasons from growth it will need to
address three key areas building talent
handling complexity and improving
commercial and development execution
handling complexity refers to the
scaling up of the tech finance and
investment vehicles and keeping up with
the speed of innovation
and then improving commercial and
development execution mainly refers to
the idea that scientists are trained as
well scientists and we focus on the
biology when it's more important to
appreciate how their product fits into
the market and competitors to better
meet investors expectations
but all in all the field is still young
given the current trajectory of
rejuvenation biotech the pace of new
discoveries in this field and the amount
of capital coming into the sector
rejuvenation science and biotech will
most likely explode in the coming years
now whether i'm biased by what i read
online which is very likely damn echo
chambers but rejuvenation biotech does
seem to be the next big frontier in
biotech although i still don't think we
are over with the crispr and the mrna
delivery systems
in fact they are being incorporated by
these companies and also just aging
longevity in general can be considered
in its own big blossoming of interest
and investment at the moment too
but anyway i'm just a kid with a
computer who does science research and i
evidently don't know everything about
biotech but what i do know is that there
are now many biotech job opportunities
available especially in new startups
and this is why i'd like to thank the
sponsor for this week's video
workingbiotech.com
workingbiotech.com
is the perfect platform for finding job
opportunities at small biotech startup
companies
it's up to date with new jobs added
daily easy to use and lists job
opportunities from research scientists
supervisors to accountants
i've already been using it to think of
potential job opportunities for when i
finished my phd
you can find the link to the site in the
description below
so i hope you've learned something in
this video thank you to my patreon
supporters and thank you for listening
you